okay well Apple as we know Cory is
stepping up its efforts to produce the
Apple watch right there selling them all
over the world earlier this month
company executives met with Mexican
regulators ahead of the debut of the
smart watches and this also comes
corneas Apple CEO Tim Cook is set to
visit Brussels today and Tel Aviv on
Wednesday which raises a question or
you're raising the question which is why
is he traveling the world so much why is
he Corey well look it's a different
world for Apple not just because of the
biggest company of the world in terms of
market cap rent a prized value or cash
hoard and that's an important aspect of
his world travels but the the release of
the Apple watch which they have not said
it's going to go beyond the United
States but we're getting that suspicion
because we know some of what happened in
his globe-trotting of what happened in
Mexico and some of the issues that were
discussed were revealed because the
government was acquired to do so in
those private meetings and they said
they met was meeting with healthcare
officials specifically to talk about
developments in the world of healthcare
and it probably relates to the the
devices world like their Apple watch
similar meetings took place in the US
but also in Brussels is on is on the
agenda as is going to the tech hub of
Israel and you know for this company
when they want to sell this medical
monitoring device when issues of privacy
have been raised not just by Apple and
the the breach of the celebrity accounts
at the Oscars and the you know we saw
some of that stuff from Apple the
regulars want to know what they're doing
in terms of privacy and the regulars
want to know what this medical device
will do yeah should it be regulated the
country's worth sold and obviously that
is very important but the overall
international market is hugely important
to Tim Cook right Corey surely and and
the cash for that Apple has stashed is
largely overseas or increasingly
overseas that's been an issue that has
compelled cook to meet with regulators
in the States and me with regular is it
overseas of course the issues of the
eeyore very important too and this issue
of privacy is something that will start
in to bang a drum on they have a
different take on privacy than
competitors like Facebook and Google
companies that gather a lot of data on
their users as the users use their
services and then they mind that data
they save that data they saw
that data and and sell things to their
users as a result apple takes the stands
that we don't make money that way we
make money by selling devices we don't
want to know what you're doing is with
your data so as they're building data
centers around the world this starts to
be an important thing for them a point
of differentiation that they want to
make very clear to regulators as
regulators start to look at this issue
of privacy because a bigger and bigger
deal